[Musik]
also rufen mich nicht auch aussehen
okay ich mache jetzt solange nichts
anderes mehr
es kann wir sehen gestand eine minute
halten kann
vielleicht sollte ich mit anleitung
dieses video wird unterstützt von huawei
na ja also das haus in christiania von
denen dieses tutorial ist redet er von
fünf einfachen schritten und das ist der
erste davon der pike holt ich habe das
gefühl ich muss nicht mal denen okay ich
gucke jetzt mal so na ja der zweite
schritt ist jetzt eine wall box
rückwärts die wand hoch zu gehen und
danach wieder zurück
[Musik]
hahaha
schritt 4 hens and present release
[Musik]
schritt 5 die landung
ich habe das gefühl das hätte von anfang
an bringen sollen naja jetzt runter
kommt will ich jetzt dadurch dass sie
mich so soll weg bringen und damit als
fußballer in der theorie dass warnung
ich für mich weil mein richtigen anstatt
zu probieren
[Musik]
hier bin ich also vor fünf jahren konnte
ich den anstand für fünf bis zehn
sekunden
jetzt habe ich genau zehn tage zeit um
wieder von null aus anzufangen und eine
ganze minute daraus zu machen
ich kann mich einfach viel zu wenig gas
zu geben anstatt überzugehen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wieso aber es läuft heute
viel besser ich so über nacht hat sich
glaubt daran weil man die muskeln nicht
mehr komplett kaputt so wie gestern
abend das mit dem was ich eigentlich gar
nicht gerechnet hat ist dass man hier
ein muskelkater kriegt und zwar in dem
bein mit dem ich mich quasi immer hoch
schleuder wir spielen das ganze mal ein
wenig vor und zwar zu tag 4 4 sekunden
wie hier habe ich auch schon an tag 3
geschafft aber heute gelingt mir zum
ersten mal zweistellig um zum ersten mal
resultate zu sehen die sich für mich
schon fast unmenschlich anfühlen
springen wir zu tag 6
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum stoppen meiner zeit wird sich
übrigens meine huawei watch fed dies
hier besonders praktisch weil ich
während des anstandes oder beim sport
generell ja wohl schlecht ein handy
aufholen kann
hände hoch stoppuhr starten und letzter
20 sekunden als aber die huawei watch
fit ist auch mein puls und das bringt
mich jetzt auch eine idee wie viel höher
ist mein puls beim handstand mein
ruhepuls in den letzten tagen lag hier
in der kurve helfer bei 66 aber wenn ich
einen handstand machen
man springt ja schon mal auf 111 in der
hälfte sehe ich übrigens auch von wann
bis wann ich wie lange geschlafen habe
und in welcher schlafphase ich war um
ein schaf zu optimieren aber zurück zum
anstand
was euch wahrscheinlich auch schon
aufgefallen ist sind meine hubers pro
mit denen ich beim sport musiker kabel
würden hier natürlich in meine hände
reinhängen und stören beim sport ja
generell ein angenehmer nebeneffekt der
privat froh ist dass ich dank des
aktiven neue scans linken nicht so laut
wie sehr ich die wohnung jetzt zum
scheppern bringen alle infos zu hohe
watch fit und den free walls pro findet
eine video beschreibung
[Musik]
zuerst stand des tages wisst ihr ich
habe mich gefragt ich war mir nicht
sicher ob ich diese clips wo ich die
handstände macht einfach so an den cut
drehen lassen soll
ich habe gedacht okay vielleicht finden
dass ein paar leute langweilig wenn es
einfach so ungeschnitten brennen ist
aber nur so wisst ihr dass es echt ist
und ich finde es sieht schon echt heftig
aus
[Musik]
vieles was diese kunden also das will
sie schon so übel ich an ich habe keinen
plan
es muss noch mehr als doppelt so lang
sein aber ich hab also richtiges gefühl
dafür gekriegt nicht meine fuß bewegen
musste mich halt nicht direkt umgibt
[Musik]
stoppt das ziel bei dem handstand ist
natürlich die perfekte haltung und die
klappt bei mir immer so gut aber ich
finde hier sieht es echt ziemlich
surreal aus wie stabile ich da stehe
man könnte meinen ich würde niemals
umfallen und eine sekunde später 25
sekunden aber nur hätte es fühlt sich an
wie eine halbe ewigkeit
das war mein handy und dann kann man
natürlich auf seinen händen auch noch
gehen
[Musik]
wo aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen mein
handgelenk trotzdem richtig weh tut er
sich aufwärmt
das ist echt unangenehm also ich fühle
also man merkt er dass händel nicht
dafür ausgelegt sind so viel gewicht zu
tragen
und wieder mal die frage soll ich das
ding jetzt wirklich einfach
ungeschnitten drin lassen und euch damit
langweilen aber ich finde beim handstand
geht es darum sich zeit zu lassen und
die balance zu genießen und die habe ich
wirklich genossen
es sieht einfach aus als welt
eingefroren und das auch wenn meine
haltung zu wünschen übrig lässt denn am
besten würde ich natürlich meine füße
gerade nach oben strecken
[Musik]
neuer rekord mein gott oh mein gott
30 kommt weil ich schlecht dass sie
überhaupt wenn ich mir jetzt vorstellen
muss man sich das ganze ding doch
bettina h
[Musik]
ok ich muss irgendwie über einer minute
kommt das muss heute klappen oder das
muss man abhaken
ich hab noch weniger als zwölf stunden
zeit
[Musik]
so
letztlich weiß wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit wo es was ich jetzt
am allerletzten tag von von 30 einfach
komplett 3 auf 60 sekunden aber mit dem
guten persönlichkeit schafft nicht ich
kann es ich kann das wirklich schaffen
also auf geht
[Musik]
runde
hätte sich fünf größten
die auf werbung am geringsten
ob das jetzt ist mein gott oh mein gott
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich fliege es fühlt sich an als wäre es
das normalste der welt alles in balance
als hätte ich nie etwas anderes gemacht
[Musik]
mühelos keine anstrengungen keinen
schwanken keine angst um titel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich gehe nicht weg und ich gehe nicht
[Musik]
game
vielleicht kennt ihr das spricht man den
mond erreichen will muss nach den
sternen greifen und wir haben definitiv
nach den sternen gegriffen mit unserer
minute und die habe ich wirklich bald
verpasst aber wie 40 sekunden die sind
schon echt heftig also für den mund hat
es gereicht ich muss auf jeden fall noch
an meiner technik arbeiten aber
natürlich auch an meiner muskelkraft und
da fand zehn tage leider für mich nicht
genug aber ich weiß zu 100 prozent dass
es nur noch eine frage der zeit ist weil
ich will die minute auf jeden fall
knappen den link zu den urwald freebuys
pro und der baywatch findet in der video
beschreibung und wenn ihr jetzt schon
wissen wollte welches video nächste wahl
kommt dann schaut gerne mal auf ins tor
vorbei dort habe ich immer mal wieder
kleinere hinweise macht's gut bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]